tale as old as time song as old as rhyme
Beauty and the Beast we remember a few
months ago they released The Lion King
in theaters in 3d and I loved it because
the lion Kings like one of the best
movies ever made so now they're doing
Beauty and the Beast also converted into
3d so I've always professed the Golden
Age of Disney 4 mese Beauty and the
Beast Aladdin and Lion King they just
got better and better at that point or
so the story goes there is Belle Belle
is arguably one of the hottest Disney
chicks ever made if not the hottest and
Belle's father's a little crazy so
inadvertently Belle's father ends up in
this castle in this castle lies the
Beast the Beast is pretty bitter and
remorseless so he just takes Belle's old
man and just locks him up in a dungeon
you know that's what beast is due to old
dudes
so Belle goes looking for her dad finds
him and tells the Beast you know what
I'll take his place I'll stay here with
you and pieces like lattes Disney chick
ever ok and of course they hate each
other because the Beast has no manners
whatsoever I can say it's not really
Belle's fault Belle's perfectly polite
Beast is not like that one thing with a
beast tells her to come down to dinner
and she's not opening the door and he's
like fine then you can stay here in stop
every time I always see that I'm like I
know someone like that that's funny ah
uncle's although she did get a bit
Snoopy there for a second you don't
snoop in the beast castle where he tells
you not to go any more than you snoop in
a guy's computer into a folder called
new folder into another folder called
new stuff into another folder titled
randomly asdf yeah you don't snoop into
these things it's just rude same goes
for the beasts castle and when I was
watching this elves like I remember
loving this movie but I don't know that
I'm gonna buy the fact that she ends up
loving the Beast by the end you know if
she does but then it kind of warms up
you're like all right yeah I see where
this is going alright so word I can say
for it it's sweet and of course there's
Gaston now Gaston is one of the town's
people who's like you know the perfect
physical specimen and all that he goes
hunting he talks like this and he has a
big chin with a cleft in it you know cuz
he's Gaston Gaston is pretty much that
guy if Gaston lived today he would live
and die by halo call of duty modern
warfare and Ghost Recon it's just a fact
of life and you know Gaston causes the
conflict in the movie and he's pretty
good at it because no one likes Gaston
chicks out there do you think Gaston is
like hot I'm just wondering I'm just
I don't know I think Bella's hot so it's
not weird I'm just wondering what you
think I know a girl who told me she
thought Mufasa was sexy so nothing's
weird here now the whole thing is that
Belle and beast fall in love the spell
will be broken and all the little
utensils will go back to normal and
beast will become a man again wish the
utensils are awesome Cogsworth and
Lumiere they're funny they're comedic
relief and that's what Disney does well
Disney does comedy relief with side
characters that's not really forced and
everyone likes is that really a lot of
annoying characters in Disney movies and
people will say that these Disney movie
re-releases in 3d are cash grabs and
yeah you know what they are but at least
they're not bad movies I can say that at
least I'm not really seing Phantom
Menace or anything like that it's next
month is it worth seeing in 3d well you
can buy the blu-ray right now so I don't
know about that you can either see it in
3d in theaters once for like 14 bucks a
ticket or you can buy the blu-ray right
now for 20 and have it forever I'm cheap
enough I would go with the blu-ray I
think they actually sell the 3d blu-ray
right now too so if you have a 3d TV
yeah but in any case this movie still
holds up isn't he had the magic and the
magic shines today so beating the beast
is still awesome tacular
what I liked about beating the Beast is
pretty much what I like about these
Disney movies in general the movies had
a point they were entertaining but they
taught a lesson for Beauty and the Beast
is that beauty's not just skin deep love
lies within or be patient don't scream
at chicks when they don't want to come
out of the room and eat dinner with you
or something there was a point to the
movie and a point to the lesson now it
just feels like things aren't like that
anymore you want a good family movie
that you're all gonna enjoy this not too
long it's like 90 minutes long Beauty
and the Beast right there which you can
buy on blu-ray right now I'm just sayin
so your favorite Disney movie I probably
asked you that and The Lion King but hey
we got new people at this point comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
Gaston says so this Xbox 360 is
perfectly enjoyable Belle get me a beer